-Watched
the first episode of this.
I found it really engaging.
Do you remember where you were
when this all happened,
because, of course, when
you watch stories like these,
you go, "Oh, 1993.
I remember this being
on the news all the time."
-I was 12 years old.
-Mm-hmm.
I was also 12.
[ Laughter ]
-I think I remember
just that last terrible shot
of the compound in flames,
to be honest.
And I don't even know
if I really remember
that part at that age.
But, obviously, growing up
or learning some history,
being from Canada or whatnot.
-Whoo!
The one other one.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, that's my mom,
by the way.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so that's really
all I really remember.
-It's interesting 'cause I think
that's true of a lot of us.
We remember the tail end of it.
Of course,
this story takes you back.
And one of the things,
which, of course, makes sense,
when he was followed
by so many people,
is there is a charisma
and likability to him.
So you're not playing a mad man
as much
as you're playing somebody
who had this ability
to connect with people.
Was that a strange way
to approach it?
-I think that's
the right way to approach it.
I think, obviously,
during the siege,
it was very sensationalized
and one-sided
with the press and whatnot.
The Dividians
were cut off from the press.
So I think what we're doing here
is basically humanizing
not only Dave but the Dividians
and their families,
the followers.
And what he was so good at
was giving them purpose.
And I think everyone
searches for that
at some time in their life,
multiple times and whatnot.
And he was a messenger,
self-proclaimed
messenger of God.
So if he had no followers,
he's got no purpose, as well.
So he needed them
as much as they needed him.
-It was based
on a couple of books.
-Yeah.
-A couple FBI guys
and then a guy
who was in the Dividians.
-Yeah, David Thibodeau.
So we optioned
Gary Noesner's book,
who was the lead FBI negotiator.
-That's who
Michael Shannon plays, right?
-Mike Shannon, yeah.
Up-and-coming, green actor.
-Yeah, it might work out.
Might work out for him.
-Yeah.
He's amazing.
-Yeah, he's a great actor.
-Yeah, and then David Thibodeau,
one of the nine survivors
of the final siege.
And he was on set every day,
you know?
And I think that's, like,
the ultimate flattery
and validation, you know?
Day one was a sermon about joy
and being a Dividian,
and that was a big one.
So he was there
on day one, obviously,
and that was -- to have him
kind of tip the hat was --
It just let me
fly from there on.
-Obviously, you had to do a lot
of Bible study for this role.
You also had to lose a lot
of weight for this role.
-30.
-You also had to learn
how to play guitar
and sing a little bit
'cause he was a musician.
Was that
the most intimidating part?
-Uh...
I think
it's all-encompassing, for sure.
But, I mean, I was
getting voice lessons in L.A.,
and it was the second time,
and I was, like, nowhere
even near of hitting any notes.
-Your second voice lesson?
-Yeah, second voice lesson.
Get in there, walk in,
and it was --
You know, there's a gal that
was doing Broadway or whatnot
right with the piano
and the teacher.
And I literally just sat back,
and she was incredible.
And they went like five minutes
over, and they stop,
and I'm kind of
just sitting there,
just, you know,
listening, loving it.
And, she's like, "Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry. I'm a big fan.
I just ran over,"
and I'm like, "Well..."
I'm talking
to the coach at this point.
I'm like,
"Well, you start at a 10,
and then now we're gonna start
like below zero,
and, like,
I'm gonna make your ears bleed."
-Well, that's the depressing
thing when you go
and you realize people
who are great
are also getting voice lessons.
You were like,
"Oh, I thought this was all
for people who were terrible."
[ Laughter ]
-There's, like, a picture of
Celine Dion right next to me.
-Yeah, I got a feeling
you and Celine
weren't starting
from the same --
It's not a level playing field.
-No.
-So, I want to ask,
"Friday Night Lights,"
fantastic show.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm assuming you get
approached all the time.
How do people
approach you in that show?
Like, is there just an emotional
connection constantly?
-One, they want to get drunk
with Tim Riggins.
-Yeah, that makes sense.
-Which, yeah,
Tim would do that a lot.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, I mean, I live in Austin,
Texas, which is an amazing city,
and so it's --
obviously, being in Texas,
you get a bit more of it.
But people, you know,
are just incredibly flattering,
and they want to have a drink
with you 90% of the time
or talk about Coach.
-Yeah.
-Who still
lives in Austin, as well.
-That, I feel like --
You're making it hard for people
by living in the city
it was filmed,
because you can't say to them,
"Hey, that's not me,"
and they'd be like, "Well,
then you should've moved."
-Yeah, totally.
[ Laughter ]
I'm still
living in the past, I think.
-So, I'm gonna
make a weird leap here,
but David Koresh
was a failed musician,
to some degree, or a musician.
-Yes.
-And there is something
about music and sermonizing
and connecting with an audience
in the same way you do
as a religious leader.
I think we share a great love
of Bruce Springsteen.
-Yes, we do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And he's on Broadway right now.
I thought -- I actually --
It was very close to
a religious experience for me.
-Yes.
-You went a couple nights ago?
-I did.
-How was it?
-Oh, man.
He raised me, that guy.
-Yeah.
-He really did.
I just...
I was just blown away.
I cried, I laughed.
It's just --
As much
as he's telling his story,
you just --
he takes you back.
And it's just like
you remember these beats
of your first kiss to, you know,
traveling in the car, obviously,
or the first time
you went camping,
or all of these kind of beats
throughout your life.
So it was just incredible.
-The other thing about it is,
not the cheapest tickets
you're ever gonna buy.
-No.
-And then, I don't --
During the show,
I had this realization of,
"I would've paid 10 times --"
-Yeah.
-"This is worth 10 --
This is the biggest deal
I've ever gotten."
-I came out of there,
and I went with my best friend,
and I'm like, "I would've
easily paid way more for that."
-Yeah.
-It was
a life-altering experience.
-I threw money
onstage at the end.
-Oh, really?
I threw panties.
My panties were up there.
-[ Laughs ]
-No.
-Thanks so much for being here.
-Congrats on the show.
Really a pleasure.